hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2016 japanese live-action movie called
higanjimo or nirvana island the last 47
days
the movie begins with a high school
student called cato who is stranded on
an island after his ship was attacked by
a mysterious sea monster he explores the
island and comes across a small village
where he finds a dying human trapped in
a jar begging for help
not long after he discovers several
vampires consuming human flesh
cato screams but it just awakens the
whole village who start chasing him he
attempts to fight back but is then
cornered by the vampire villagers
luckily a man shows up and eliminates
several vampires
however since they are outnumbered they
decide to flee to the woods
after they run far enough the man
reveals his identity cato is shocked
when he recognizes that the man was his
schoolmate ken who disappeared several
months ago alongside other as friends
kato reveals that he embarks to the
island to rescue them but later regrets
the decision after ken tells him that
higanjima is a vampire island and the
other friends are still alive
cato initially does not believe the
story
but it turns out that ken has been
infected and he suddenly turns into a
vampire with red eyes
ken orders his friend to run away as he
is unwilling to drink his own friend's
blood
the scene moves to akira and cato's
other friends who initially came to the
island to find akira's missing brother
since they are trapped akira has to
train hard in order to protect his
friends from the emerging vampires he is
also being mentored by a masked man
aoyama who has been teaching him how to
be a strong fighter after a long fight
they managed to eliminate all the
vampires easily
however a terrifying creature suddenly
appears and attacks akira out powered
ayama shows up and helps his student to
battle the giant creature they team up
and eventually manage to beat the
creature without any casualties
a few moments later the vampire leader
miyabi shows up and congratulates him
for beating the monster
filled with hatred akira immediately
rushes towards him and attacks him
impressed with akira's fighting skill
miyabi offers him to join the vampire
side but is rejected thus the vampire
leader summons more ugly creatures to
kill akira while he is fighting the
monsters one of akira's friends yuki
attempts to kill miyabi with an arrow
but he sees that coming and bites her on
the neck sucking her blood realizing
that his crush is being attacked akira
immediately attacks miyabi in the battle
between them ensues
at some point akira manages to land his
sword on the vampire's body but it turns
out that miyabi is immortal and there is
no way to kill him now
since akira keeps rejecting the offer to
join the vampire side miyabi threatens
to infect yuki into a vampire but
suddenly can who has been secretly
observing them shoots an arrow towards
miyabi's eye and they use this
opportunity to run away turns out that
ken is yuki's ex-boyfriend before he was
transformed into a vampire that's why he
keeps observing her from a distance to
ensure her safety the next day aoyama
reveals that the only way to kill the
vampires is beheading them but it
doesn't apply to miyabi fortunately
aoyama reveals that they have found the
location of a vaccine which is the only
weapon to kill the vampire leader they
immediately plan a strategy to break
into the facility where the vaccine is
being kept
on the other side miyabi is aware of the
presence of the vaccine and immediately
orders his secret fighter to secure it
before akira obtains it back to cato he
arrives at a small village where he
discovers atsushi akira's missing
brother is actually still alive and
becomes the village's leader one of the
villagers who has become a vampire
refuses to drink blood and suddenly
transforms into an alien-like monster
atsushi has to eliminate him as he has
become a threat for the other villagers
after that kato greets atsushi who
recognizes him and reveals that vampires
have to drink blood to sustain their
human form
unfortunately atsushi and the other
villagers have also been infected but
they are not dangerous
atsushi then escorts cato to a hidden
facility in the middle of the island and
then he suddenly disappears leaving him
alone there
the next day akira and the team invade
the laboratory but it is guarded by the
vampires the fight ensues but as
expected akira and the others manage to
eliminate the vampires easily ken
finally reveals himself to yuki and
protects her from the emerging vampires
meanwhile an enormous monster whose body
is covered by eyes appears and attacks
akira the monster has a 360 degree view
so it is difficult for akira to attack
from behind
it is too strong for him and akira is
cornered but suddenly atsushi shows up
and rescues his younger brother who is
very shocked when he discovers that his
elder brother is still alive
they team up and manage to defeat the
monster however atsushi tells akira to
keep distance from him since he has
become a vampire and vampires are
humanity's worst enemies akira then
regroups with his friends and they
proceed to the laboratory through a
tunnel
suddenly a horde of vampires emerge and
attack them luckily they are slow and
the group manages to eliminate all of
them easily
after a long walk they arrive at the
laboratory where they come across again
with a group of vampires
as usual akira and the others slaughter
all the vampires one of them shishon
gets bitten by the vampires but he will
be okay since it is not a deep wound
after the battle they obtain the vaccine
to kill miyabi however otsushi
surprisingly shows up again and
threatens to kill akira if he doesn't
hand over the vaccine turns out that
atsushi has picked sides with miyabi and
attacks his own brother he even slashes
one of akira's friends who tries to stop
him the girl gives her last words before
she passes away begging akira to save
the island atsushi doesn't care and
takes the vaccine with him and goes away
from there
the group suddenly hears strange noises
from the other room and coincidentally
meets kato there
not long after an enormous centipede
monster with a human face walks by but
it won't attack them as long as they do
not see its eyes they then ascend to the
top of the building through ladders
where cato stumbles and accidentally
sees its eyes the monster enrages and
begins to attack the group ruthlessly
they panic and run as fast as they can
they eventually reach the top of the
building and barely escape from the
centipede monster they continue their
journey to find an exit door and come
across a small wagon which they believe
will lead them to the exit door
unfortunately the wagon is stuck and the
enraged monster emerges again
akira manages to push the wagon and they
escape from the monster but it keeps
chasing them away they desperately throw
several bombs towards the monster
causing it to find alternative route to
chase the group
they celebrate as they think the monster
has gone but it suddenly shows up in
front of them and marches towards them
at a very high speed
lucky for them the wagon is thrown
before they collide causing them to keep
moving through the monster's body and
eventually escape from the facility in
the centipede
after that akira realizes that on sushi
is not his brother anymore and he has to
fight him in order to retrieve the
vaccine he then meets atsushi at the
village and fights him there the battle
ensues but it seems like atsushi is
still too strong for akira he doesn't
give up and eventually manages to stab
him in the chest
the dying out sushi transforms into a
vampire saying that it will now be a
battle between a human and vampire and
flees to an ancient tomb akira chases
after him to the tomb where the fight
between the brothers continues
atsushi manages to bite akira in the
neck and sucks his blood until he almost
faints
luckily he manages to stab him in the
eye which stops the sucking they
exchange punches until at some point
akira is able to overpower his brother
and punches him ruthlessly the punches
cause the column above them to fall down
but atsushi pushes his brother away
causing him to be hit by the rocks
instead atsushi reveals that he was
forced to work with miyabi to protect
his village and then order zakira to
behead him so that he can rest forever
akira initially refuses to fulfill the
request since he is still his brother
however he eventually finishes his own
brother after realizing there is no way
to bring his brother back to being human
the other villagers realize that they
will bring no good to humanity since
they have become vampires so they decide
to suicide
on the other side miyabi has expected
the fight and orders his girls to launch
a surprise attack on akira's village
miyabi's men arrive at the village and
slaughter every remaining human there
amma yuki and akira's other friends are
cornered and outnumbered since the girls
also summon the huge terrifying monsters
even the gigantic centipede monster also
present there back to the tomb akira and
kato retrieve the vaccine but suddenly
miyabi appears and congratulates akira
for killing his own brother
again miyabi offers akira to become his
henchman but this statement just makes
akira furious and immediately attacks
him akira vows that he will eliminate
every single vampire on that island and
save humanity after that the final
battle between the strongest human on
the island and the vampire leader begins
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching